hallo leute ich in eurem wahn und
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
werde ich mal schauen wie es ist mit
langen fingernägeln zu leben
ich finde es irgendwie total cool aber
ich glaube es ist so so unpraktisch ich
habe meinen laptop aufgeklappt und schon
versucht mit meiner schwester zu
schreiben und man könnte sein dass ich
irgendwie ein schlaganfall habe oder so
weil ich keinen satz richtig schreiben
können damit ich keine zeit vertrödelt
geben wir uns jetzt schminken da habe
ich angst mit meinem mikrofasertuch 5000
mache ich mir erst mal meine schwarzen
augenringen
aber hier ist der fingernagel ganz
praktisch weil es im richtigen pixar es
schön jetzt muss ich an meine augen run
lidschatten prima die angst man muss
jetzt alles so flachmann okay das
funktioniert sonst besser ich habe angst
ich bin so limitiert in meinem jetzt
denke ich da schon aber ich will so in
die ecke
ok es wird schwieriger ich komme nämlich
hier ein ganz entgegen meine wange
boom so ich muss mir angewöhnt zu
frühstücken
deswegen frühstücken wir jetzt und ich
habe früh stück gekauft eine auswahl ist
sehr kreativ einmal porridge wohl und
bars mit deren geschmack und plain eine
taste eineinhalb tassen milch
das wird so schöne rot und so schnell
macht man sich ein gesundes frühstück
leute so gesteckt dass jetzt einfach mal
wie ein erwachsener mensch schaffen
nicht zu kleckern beimessen so ich
frische wir dann jetzt mal zu ende und
dann geht es ins büro danke für die
erfindung von schuh anziehen das war
wirklich schwer geworden du darfst du
wärst du du bist es mir doch gar nicht
so habe ich in den handel ein bisschen
ja sollte zum 100
so paket öffnen mit fingernägeln ohne
fingernägel würde ich das wahrscheinlich
auch nicht auf kriegen also ich muss
sagen ich habe schon extreme anzugehen
diesem wege nicht fassen kann nicht ich
kann nicht richtig sein
wir brauchen jetzt ein pc für mein neues
büro am spending money
jetzt gehts uns wenn es geht wo es geht
auf jeden fall nicht dass ich vielleicht
hier
ich mache ich was mache ich hier
eigentlich willkommen in meinem büro bin
jetzt alleine hier und es halt noch mega
und autor hat nie wieder steht hier
gelassen und greifen also ich zeige euch
mal was bis hin zu haben
das ist ein teppich habe ich welche
tiere gekauft der säulen den schein
bisschen wegnimmt couch ist von meinem
zimmer ich habe jetzt aber noch ein
zweiter teppich gekauft haben ja nicht
ausgepackt
ich habe angst mit dem winter liegen zu
brechen
irgendwie ist es pervers
das ist in einem stück komplett so wie
es ist abgefallen so leute ich gehe
jetzt nach hause
[Musik]
willkommen zuhause ich muss bügel üben
sollte ja nicht allzu schwer sein mögen
ist so spannend
ich raste aus soeben muss den nagel
nummer zwei ich habe versucht mein
tolles mallorca mehr als ein stein habe
ich noch gefunden muss dieser nagel
roman der daumen ist wirklich das am
aufwändigsten beklebte stück und hätten
es einfach so eine sache nicht am
meisten auf die gewählt hatte langfinger
wäsche machen mit nägeln den ring
greifen
[Musik]
aber euch zugegriffen
also ich sage wie es ist wenn mit langen
fingernägeln tut einfach weh
eigentlich müsste man gerade im
klettersteig ich nicht aufpasse mit
meinem auge der tag ist vorbei und jetzt
ist es zeit für ein fazit bin ich der
meinung dass man mit langen fingernägeln
den alltag bewältigen kann nein glaube
ich nicht ich finde es ist viel zu
verrückt wie sehr man eingeschränkt ist
durch so lange fingernägel im block war
das noch der erste tag da war noch alles
gut da hat sich noch alles schön
angefühlt es gab ein paar probleme aber
mittlerweile ist die hälfte schon
abgebrochen jetzt sie wieder dran
geklebt und ich dachte es wäre ganz
witzig wenn mein nageldesigner mein male
artist ein nagelstudio mensch mal meine
arbeit bewertet bevor er sie kaputt
macht ich bin nämlich sehr gespannt was
er dazu zu sagen hat und wie er findet
dass ich gearbeitet habe ich erwarte
nicht viel aber schauen gemacht so ich
bin jetzt angekommen im studio
[Musik]
auf der fahrt es mir ein ich habe die
tür vom auto zu gemacht und dann ja der
abgebauten was sagst du ja aber gar
nicht ausgestanden sind sind so strass
steinen wir sind halt alle schon
abgebrochen
nein sind abgebrochen noch einen tag
okay also ich kann daran liegen dass man
muss vorher richtig aber schön auf den
ersten blick oder ich glaube einfach ich
mache einfach abnahm
ja einfach bock hat sich sehr
ich habe sechs stunden dafür braucht
weil ich habe diese steine halt so
einmal aufgeklärt kraft und wie vor bei
wenigen dass du das ich bin so
enttäuscht das hat sich so stabil an
gefühl dass ich so drauf gemalt habe
[Musik]
manche vom geld eigentlich angst dass
spitz gar nicht so schlecht aber wir
wissen natürlich auch die ja sechsten
rang
[Musik]
ich habe gesehen dass die uniklinik der
hier das bald hier erhält man tipps
kriegst du immer hier nur an
vorne wo die verlängerung so sagt
[Musik]
also sieht auf jeden fall schon mal ist
groß das werden sie vorn gemacht
[Musik]
das bleibt die länge gefühl so lang
waren wie susanne zusammen so sieht das
also vom profi aus
[Musik]
ich kann's mir ein cappuccino was machst
du jetzt drauf habt uns vermitteln warum
brennt das dass alkohol
[Musik]
ich habe in den kommentaren gelesen dass
man ganz gut aus
wer schön sein kann ich jetzt eigentlich
so einfach dabei einschlagen
[Musik]
das ich lege die eklig sind manchmal
aber es ist leider so dass also der
gehwege sie natürlich schwierig machen
das ist schon jemand mal welcher hand
ohne zu bezahlen
ja aber echt auch so sehen nur achte und
jajaja volvo ebenmäßig das bekommt ihr
nur im studio treffen waren in der
altstadt
[Musik]
ich möchte
hier also schön kannst auch so höher das
herz schwereres so richtig groß größer
schneller auch hier machen muss nicht
nur einer spitze sein
[Musik]
vom herzen es ist schön
und so stand wechseln
hier kam man zu
wirklich gut aus aber auch schon richtig
gut auch wenn gott ich liebe das ist so
gut wie brechen jetzt aber nicht so
schnell aber ich kann sachen wieder
greifen
es fühlt sich so ebenmäßig an
mit zwei steinen und fertig wird stoppt
die zeit um mein gott vor sind die
diesen so schön ich raste aus
[Musik]